nos encontramos con bolodomir ya bolsky
que es investigador de Derechos Humanos
abogado y también integrante del centro
por la libertad de civiles ganador del
premio Nobel de la paz el año pasado
Lleva más de 25 años trabajando en el
campo de los Derechos civiles y ahora
hace parte también de ese gran grupo que
Investiga los crimen crímenes de guerra
cometidos por Rusia no solamente desde
el comienzo de la invasión el año pasado
sino desde el 2014 bolo dormir gracias
por estar con France 24 en español y
para empezar
remontémonos hacia el 24 de febrero de
hace un año usted lleva investigando
muchísimos años crímenes de guerra qué
pensaba que iba a invadir usted cómo se
sintió que hizo
obviamente entendía que habría una
guerra lo creía y lo sabía lo que no
tenía claro era que fuera posible que se
diera en esa magnitud
en ese momento tomé a mi hijo recogí mis
cosas y nos fuimos al occidente de
Ucrania que era más seguro que quedarnos
en kiev estuvimos fuera de aquí durante
tres meses pero después de eso regresé
una guerra es un reto para cualquier
persona especialmente para quienes
investigan crímenes de lesa humanidad y
activistas de Derechos Humanos Cuál ha
sido el mayor reto no solamente para
usted sino para todos quienes trabajaban
en esta organización por las libertades
civiles Durante este año
[Música]
los Derechos Humanos son lo opuesto a la
guerra y por lo tanto defender los
derechos humanos durante una guerra son
un gran desafío
de hecho nos acabamos de encontrar con
esta situación porque nunca hemos visto
violaciones de Derechos Humanos a una
escala tan grande en nuestras vidas
[Música]
una cosa así no ha sucedido en Europa
durante muchas décadas no teníamos idea
de que esto era posible y claro Son
miles decenas de miles de crímenes que
se han cometido y que han quedado
impunes
necesitábamos poner en marcha muy
rápidamente alguna actividad específica
para contrarrestar esto en qué momento
después de esa invasión a gran escala
ustedes se dieron cuenta de la dimensión
de lo que estaba pasando de los crímenes
que se estaban cometiendo fue esto en
bucha en irpín en qué lugar realmente
dijeron esto que se nos viene por
delante es bastante bastante grande
quedó claro de inmediato primero hemos
estado monitoreando y recopilando
información sobre delitos desde 2014
tanto en el este del país como en crimea
por lo tanto para nosotros las tácticas
del ejército ruso no son nuevas y por
eso estábamos preparados para ello vimos
cuando empezaron a bombardear las
primeras ciudades con aviones cuando los
aviones sobrevolaron Cherry gif y
bombardearon o cuando empezaron los
primeros arrestos en el este En la
región de gersón o en saporilla entonces
fue obvio que los abusos serían masivos
y habría grandes violaciones de Derechos
Humanos
muchas veces cuando hablamos de esa
invasión el 24 de febrero se nos olvida
o en el mundo olvidamos que ustedes
venían en guerra desde el 2014 y venían
haciendo este tipo de trabajo y de
investigación sobre los crímenes Pero
cómo se puede comparar la escala de
estos atropellos Y estos crímenes antes
del 2014 y lo que han visto en este
último año hay algún cambio
cuando imaginamos la guerra normalmente
son soldados luchando contra soldados
pero cuando imaginamos una guerra rusa
está luchando contra la población lucha
en general contra todos los que no
obedecen a Rusia es decir si dices que
eres ucraniano si de alguna manera no
apoya sus acciones Rusia luchará contra
estos civiles y esto es precisamente lo
que diferencia a esta guerra de tantas
otras porque se Libra contra la
población civil
particularmente en Las Guerras Se buscan
crímenes simbólicos que puedan permitir
llevar luego a aquellos criminales a una
Corte Internacional pero ustedes
decidieron en esta organización y en
Ucrania investigar cada uno de sus
pequeños crímenes cometidos por las
fuerzas rusas en el país porque han
hecho esto y Cuál es la dimensión desea
objetivo que se han propuesto
creemos que la impunidad engendra estos
crímenes es decir los rusos no se
habrían comportado aquí de manera tan
irresponsable Y tan descarada hacia al
menos hubieran asumido la posibilidad de
su responsabilidad Rusia les enseñó que
nunca son responsables de nada y de
hecho si van a responder creemos que
este es uno de los elementos más
importantes para que esto no vuelva a
suceder en el futuro por lo tanto
buscamos pasar los próximos 10 20 años
intentando que se haga justicia y esto
no es solo un problema de los tribunales
internacionales porque la mayoría de los
casos se considerarán en los tribunales
ucranianos esto toma mucho tiempo mucho
esfuerzo ahora Estamos ayudando al
gobierno ucraniano a construir un
sistema que funcione para investigar y
castigar a los culpables muy comenzada
la guerra vimos esos primeros juicios a
soldados rusos que cometieron atropellos
dentro de Ucrania Cómo siguen esos
juicios se siguen dando sabemos bastante
poco pero Cuál es la situación
actualmente respecto a esto
hay tales casos son simplemente muy
complicados hasta la fecha hay 95 casos
en tribunales ucranianos contra igual
número de militares rusos todavía hay
muchos casos bajo investigación incluso
ya se ha establecido quien es culpable
El problema es que no los podemos
encontrar porque están del lado ruso por
lo tanto es difícil llevarlos ante los
tribunales en esta etapa
cuando estos primeros juicios se dieron
ustedes dijeron como activistas de
Derechos Humanos que su gran reto era
verificar que esos juicios fueran justos
y que fueran realmente bien hechos que
han encontrado hasta el momento y
realmente han tenido que hacer alguna
denuncia o realmente se han sorprendido
con la manera como ha actuado la
justicia ucraniana Esta es una pregunta
difícil que por supuesto también le
hacemos al gobierno ucraniano y aquí
está la pregunta principal que se puede
responder de la siguiente manera estará
a salvo el abogado que defiende al
acusado y el juez ucraniano por ejemplo
correr riesgo de ser absuelto si no hay
pruebas suficientes contra ese Soldado y
el principio en los primeros seis meses
de la guerra teníamos muchas dudas de
que esto fuera posible fue difícil
porque había mucha presión social sobre
esta gente pero ahora no es así en
absoluto hay un juicio real en muchos
casos esto da una idea de que al menos
en principio este proceso pueda llamarse
justo es importante que Ucrania sea
parte del sistema internacional esto
significa que por ejemplo todos estos
rusos pueden acudir al tribunal europeo
de derechos humanos y sus derechos han
sido violados hay un conjunto completo
de herramientas para la protección
humana en Ucrania hoy en día en Rusia
por ejemplo no observamos esto en
absoluto
una de las grandes condiciones para
acceder a la Unión Europea la reforma de
la justicia en Ucrania sobre la que
ustedes han venido trabajando Creen que
a pesar de la guerra y a pesar de las
dificultades esto ha servido como
oportunidad para el país para mejorar
ciertos aspectos incluido
ese sistema judicial
uno de los argumentos más fuertes que
usamos es que podemos usar este momento
no solo para lograr justicia sino para
llevar a cabo un cambio positivo en el
sistema legal ucraniano
y China tal como sucedió por ejemplo en
Bosnia y herzegovina o en otros países
donde se introdujeron ciertos tribunales
híbridos o formas híbridas de tribunales
y
cuando tuvimos la participación de
jueces extranjeros e investigadores
extranjeros que durante muchos años
trabajaron junto con el sistema de
aplicaciones de la ley y los jueces de
Ucrania
El Sistema Nacional interno cambió mucho
y por eso decimos que la justicia no es
solo para el castigo de estas personas
sino también para el crecimiento del
país
ustedes desde esta organización han
hablado de un tribunal en contra de
Vladimir Putin que no solamente tiene
que ver con los crímenes comprometidos
en Ucrania sino en diferentes países
donde han estado con presencia de las
tropas rusas y me refiero a chechenia me
refiero también a Georgia me refiero a
Siria Por qué hacer esto y que tan
viable es un proyecto como el que
ustedes Proponen
Esta es una tarea difícil que nos
propusimos y fue establecida por el
gobierno craneano porque hay varios
problemas sobre todo los funcionarios
más altos de Rusia tienen inmunidad
diplomática solo pueden ser procesados
por un tribunal internacional en segundo
lugar hasta la fecha no existe ningún
tribunal internacional que teóricamente
podría enjuiciar a los altos dirigentes
de la federación rusa porque la Corte
Penal Internacional no tiene
jurisdicción sobre la federación rusa
y En tercer lugar el hecho del crimen de
agresión es obvio para todos los
abogados del mundo Hay demasiadas
Guerras en el mundo y muy pocos crímenes
de agresión desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial entendemos que esto fue un
crimen de agresión y que Rusia debe
asumir la responsabilidad y para ello
necesitamos crear este tribunal
internacional porque solo él puede en
primer lugar establecer la
responsabilidad de la federación rusa
Y en segundo lugar eliminar el tema de
las inmunidades diplomáticas es decir no
serán solo algunas decisiones virtuales
pero esta dinámica podría cambiar en el
futuro
es posible hacerlo en este momento
somos uno de los que a través de
organizaciones no gubernamentales en el
mundo están tratando de lograr que la
asamblea general adopte una resolución
que crearía tal tribunal internacional
sobre la agresión de Rusia contra
Ucrania
el centro para la libertad de civiles
fue galardonado con el premio Nobel de
la paz este año un gran logro para una
organización como ustedes que están Todo
el tiempo en el terreno que ha cambiado
la vida para ustedes y Qué significa ese
premio para esta organización y todos
los que trabajan en ella
entendemos que los Derechos Humanos son
un antídoto contra la guerra y si los
Derechos Humanos fueran respetados en
Rusia Bielorrusia y otros países nunca
habrían atacado a Ucrania como
se aprecia
por eso este premio es importante para
nosotros hizo que nuestra voz Se
escuchara a nivel internacional los
gobiernos internacionales y de otros
empezaron a escuchar más nuestra voz
en particular en el contexto de la
necesidad de luchar contra las
dictaduras y castigar el mal
doctor es decir quienes cometen El
crimen de agresión deben ser sancionados
para terminar
sé que ha sido un año bastante intenso
con muchísimos casos pero me gustaría
que nos contara un caso en especial que
le ha llamado la atención que ha tocado
su corazón y que ha sido bastante duro
para ustedes trabajar
por ejemplo hay una mujer que era
maestra en la región de charling y
cuando la región de fue ocupada fue
llevada a la federación rusa en kursk
porque se negó a cooperar con los rusos
ya después de la liberación de la región
de tuvimos informes de que esta civil
estaba capturada por la federación rusa
pasaron aproximadamente más de tres
meses hasta que logramos que la
devolvieran a Ucrania
fue extraordinario cuando finalmente
regresó porque ella es una simple
maestra civil según el derecho
internacional no es posible detener a
civiles en absoluto lo que no es lo
mismo que mantenerlos en cautiverio ella
no es una prisionera de guerra
dedicamos mucho tiempo a salvarla y
ahora tenemos una lista de al menos 700
de esas personas ucranianos que están en
cautiverio
es importante que estos civiles que
nunca habían tomado las armas regresen a
casa
Muchísimas gracias bolo dormir por estar
con nosotros en France 24 en español
[Música]